welcome to another edition of matt walsh
sucks at video games so we've been doing
these videos well my producers talked me
into doing these videos where i try to
play video games even though up until
now i hadn't played a video game since
my super nintendo days back in like
fifth or sixth grade today we're going
to play
moral combat it's the it's the new
mortal kombat although i remember
playing mortal kombat this is a game i
have some familiarity with
back in the day
on super nintendo
and how much how much different can it
be you know it's been a while might be a
little bit rusty we're gonna play mortal
kombat and um i'm going to be playing
against
jacob the pa who uh jacob are you there
i'm here what's going on okay up until
this point jacob has been guiding me
supposedly has been sort of my guide my
guru through these games now he's going
to play against me i feel like his real
intentions are finally known okay so we
go to the game and the first thing we do
is we pick a player right i think for
the first one we're going to have you
play a sub-zero i mean you're going to
have me plays i can't pick my own guy
okay go ahead scroll around and pick
your own guy well why can't i pick one
whoever you want go ahead and pick them
all right so we got this sort of vaguely
gay terminator guy here
so i think i have to be someone who's my
own race is that a rule so it's not
cultural appropriation i'd have to read
the terms and conditions
and uh where is isn't there a ken
am i thinking of barbie or
isn't there ken and ryu and or am i
thinking of street fighter
why did you want me to be sub-zero uh i
mean it's the classic matchup i thought
you know for the culture for the culture
all right well as a cultural warrior if
this if this matters i'll just be
sub-zero now that we've had that
conversation all right good so i'm good
to go i'm a button smasher from way back
in the day so that's gonna be my
strategy here
don't hit me yet don't don't hit me stop
stop time out stop a second
let me figure out the buttons first
i'm not gonna hit you just let me okay
oh we forgot the buttons no wait a
second that was yeah i'm not going to
hit you nice all right
all right i feel i feel good now
i'm the blue guy right you are the blue
guy are you ready to go i'm playing okay
all right
why why am i winning
oh my gosh i'm winning
guys no one expected okay wait stop stop
time out time out time out
just wait one second i just want to talk
to you
okay how do i how do i do my magical uh
ice powers i don't know if i should tell
you that considering how the round's
going why
all right
i feel like i'm winning
oh no
well that's not that's not fair i don't
know how to do that
jake time out for can we pause it for a
second okay go pause for a sec
you can't do any moves that i don't know
how to do all right that's the rule so
i'm supposed to run around in circles
yes what the hell how many
moves are there there's there's a lot so
look if you if you feel like i'm in
medical school i got to memorize all
this information look if you if you just
go back to the game look don't come near
me
push push triangle all right i'm going
to push it in a second
i just need to stretch my legs a little
bit
okay don't hit me
nice look at that
great round this one oh there's another
one yeah
how humiliating is this going to be to
you if i actually win
don't let me win i'm not letting you in
oh you ducked under there that was nice
oh wait what's going on what's going on
stop it
stop no
oh wait that was me i just did that
i don't know i don't know what's
happening how do i get out of this
push the circle button push the circle
button
i did something good while that was
going on
i told you button button smashing is an
art it's not just luck
oh come on
this is gratuitous first of all
oh wait that was me i just did that i
did something good while that was going
on
i just had my neck smashed and i'm still
alive
yeah
i was decapitated i'm still alive all
right
cancel him
mr walsh you're professional
i just won you just won you just beat me
that's crazy how did that happen
i don't know i don't know i think uh i
think we should try again i don't know
if i want to try let me ask you a
question uh if you don't mind me asking
how old are you uh i'm 20 years old
you're only 20 years old i'm 20 years
old yes
and you just got beat by the old guy
well
you know
you you're so young like you don't even
remember a time when smartphones didn't
exist
that's true i actually don't i had a
rotary phone i remember having a rotary
phone and i just beat you okay well
mortal kombat's been around for a while
and you said you played it before so
your experience probably carried over
it's the butt i'm telling you the button
smashing is it you can't overthink okay
then maybe i should try that i'm going
to try that now i'm going to button
smash all right i'll we could do we'll
do one more round
fight all right
how do i know who's winning that's the
other question
what if nobody wins is it can you tie i
don't think so i think someone dies at
the end of every game
i might play a little bit more defense
this round
see that's the strategy
i duck in
hit you with the sword
[Music]
nice
i don't know who's doing what right now
okay that was me that just got hit
[Music]
all right we don't need to draw this out
i get it
i get it
see i don't i can't do the special moves
that's the first problem my guy can
shoot ice out of his hands can't he and
i how do i do that i don't even know
i don't know uh just button smash you
should do it eventually
i'm playing with one hand time playing
with my ice hand tied behind my back
here
[Music]
take that son of a [ __ ]
oh okay
oh come on son of a what all right final
round fight around let's all right mr
walsh oh look at that look at that this
is where you solidify your legacy
i'm telling you the triangle button
that's where it's at for me
what's going on mr walsh
oh oh
there it is ow
there it is
[Applause]
cancel him that is just
look at that
um
i kind of regret doing this video now oh
this is a great segment idea i love this
that's it
i'm not playing again what time is it i
think we're gonna go home i won twice
no i i don't remember you doing that at
all jacob you have any last words
um
i'll take i'll take that
stunned in silence
there's no comment button smashing
you can teach an old dog new tricks you
know what why don't we do it one more
time no but wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait with different
characters this time no no i'm not doing
it
i'm i won i've i won twice i'm retiring
in fact i'm retiring from video games do
i sense do i sense fear i'm retiring
from video games this is the end of the
segment
i don't know thank you for watching
flawless victory